italy's president sergio materella
announcing a 70-day timeline for early
elections clearly a decision he did not
want to take
him
the early dissolvant of parliament is
always a last resort particularly if as
it is the case in this period the
parliament has many important tasks to
complete
in the interests of our country
but the developments in the political
situation have led to this decision
his announcement came hours after mario
draghi stepped down on thursday the
prime minister made his last statement
in parliament before tendering his
resignation
[Applause]
even central bankers hearts are touched
sometimes
thank you for this and thanks for all
the work we have done together during
this time
draghi led a government for less than 18
months many leaders across europe saw
him as a steady hand to pull italy and
maybe even the whole continent out of
the pandemic he helped steer billions of
dollars of recovery funds to italy the
largest recipient in the eurozone and
was a leading voice in europe's support
of ukraine against russia
but in the end this central banker
couldn't wrangle the diverse group of
parties in his coalition each with its
own priorities
he couldn't tame the populace because
the populace of a five-star movement
splintered and during a civil war he
couldn't tame the other populists the uh
the lega from the from the right wing
because they're splitting so there's a
great um chaos right now underway while
some are lamenting the government's
collapse one party is thrilled the far
right-wing brothers of italy currently
leading in the polls looks likely to win
more seats than any other skeptical of
brussels and eu policies it's not clear
it will be able to manage relationships
with other eu leaders as well as draghi
and some worry it could even put further
eu recovery fund payouts at risk
adam rainey al jazeera rome